los huevos y las cacerolas son para
cocinar así se refirió el presidente
francés Emmanuel macron al recibimiento
que le hicieron los habitantes de grunge
donde más de 200 personas lo esperaban
para mostrar su inconformidad con la
reforma pensional al mismo tiempo en
París un grupo de manifestantes entró a
las oficinas de brunonex el operador
bursátil francés para expresar su
descontento con el enfoque de la recién
aprobada reforma
el símbolo de la bolsa es el símbolo de
gente que no tiene noción del dinero es
el símbolo de alguien que juega con
nuestra vida apretando botones Así que
sí esta acción es mediática pero también
le habla a todo el mundo señala Dónde
está el problema y que si hay dinero en
este país es gracias a nuestro trabajo
el descontento popular con las grandes
multinacionales en Francia es una
constante en las protestas a principios
de abril un grupo de trabajadores inundó
la sede de Louis Vuitton en París en una
demostración más contra la clase
privilegiada francesa el argumento de
los ciudadanos es que si alguien tiene
que responder por los problemas
financieros del sistema de pensiones son
los grandes empresarios
buscan soluciones para financiar el
sistema de pensiones hay una solución
muy sencilla sacar dinero de los
bolsillos de los multimillonarios
la reforma pensional ya fue aprobada a
pesar de meses de protestas pero la
fuerza trabajadora en Francia no da
indicios de Rendirse